[Music]
who would you invite to the beach club
to come hey I mean someone specifically
Oprah she's just a really kind warm
person and she really her heart is so
big yes it is Lindsay Lohan telling me
how Oprah's still really big influence
in her life remember that Lindsay had a
docu-series on the own Network back in
2014 now like Lindsay I would also like
to see over at the Lohan Beach Club
would that be something I contiguous
re-prep there could be a special edition
of open jails with og bottles from
Greece because that means from what we
see so far well there is no question
these besties won't answer case in point
Oprah and Gayle biggest sex fails you do
costumes no I don't do customs you know
once I schoolgirl one side oh my god
once I try nurse and he plays that no no
no no once I tried once I tried this
this is so many years ago and I got the
hold negligee thing and I'm standing at
the stairs when he comes in and he
literally comes in Steadman walks right
past me and says what are you doing oh
my god I got one better wrap myself up
with saran wrap oh you did yes I did
when I was married put on the trench
coat he came home with that uh he went
what is that Oh cuz I hear the young
people today one of spiced things up so
I would say ask him what would be spicy
you could be you know wrapping yourself
up as a pretzel you know doing
calisthenics you can get limber yeah you
could get limber and he please like what
is that Oprah and Stedman have been
together 32 years they met at a charity
event in 1986 even proposed six years
later she said yes but it got postponed
he's a very special man and that he is
not the least bit intimidated by me or
what I do I'm very grateful to have
somebody like that who is who you know
doesn't want to be in the limelight with
me isn't try isn't when you walk into a
room looking for all the cameras both
Stedman and I save is that had we
married we would not still be together
it's not a traditional relationship and
marriage is a traditional institution I
think it's more of a spiritual
partnership he wants whatever is best
for me I want whatever is best for him
okay but does the couple have any trust
issues the steadman half of your past
images now have my passcode I do not
have his I don't have your passcode I
have yours
and there is one thing both Oprah and
Gayle agree is a deal-breaker I've been
dating a guy and whenever he stays over
he wakes up and gets ready for work and
then we leave the house together but I
just found out through some detective
work that actually that he actually
doesn't have a job yikes
run oh my god Rainer this is a
no-brainer
this is so great back to Oprah's sex
life because there is more you know the
revealed yes what worked for her and
said Minh just the other day that Stella
hey oven day the other day oh yeah just
the other day
[Music]
[Applause]